our friends at manscapes are turning
their men's shower dreams into their
favorite routines the ultra premium new
collection is an all-in-one hygiene skin
and hair bundle
it's designed to upgrade your shower
from head to toe using manscape during
my showers after workout has given me
much more confidence the shower routine
uses all the collections products you
start with the cologne infused ultra
premium body wash you'll smell so great
all the ladies will be after you next
you apply the two in one shampoo and
conditioner that cleanses once you hop
out the shower apply the manscape
aluminum free deodorant if you have
tattoos or dry skin
hit your skin with a hydrating body
moisturizer spray last but not least
check out the lawn mower 4.0 electric
trimmer to clean off any unwanted body
hair the lawnmower 4.0 is
waterproof and so it can join you in the
shower
although your balls might look like
punching bags don't treat them like one
the lawn mower is designed to cut hair
on loose skin get 20 or free shipping
with code to hot boxing at
manscape.com that's 20 off free shipping
with code hotboxing at manscape.com
it's time to get wet and clean with your
new manscape shower routine
yeah
mike what the [ __ ] is that that mushroom
oh jesus oh god i thought mike just ate
a bowl of mushrooms
oh my god i almost [ __ ] on myself
oh i thought he took the whole [ __ ]
things out
mike you can't do that
guys
start the podcast
we got to get mike to the hospital
it was blackberries it was black bears
everybody calm down
oh did you see me panic just now oh god
[Music]
welcome back to hot boxing this is
season four and my co-host sebastian
here and we have the great kevin hart
how are you man season four mike good
for you buddy i'm happy as well good for
you mike i didn't think this should go
by one season right i didn't think they
want to hear this yeah man season four
congrats man uh to you to to season four
season
four all the blunts and sebastian to you
brother hey i got water i'm right here
you know you gotta get fired i'm getting
off there you know
how you doing man i'm good man what do
you mean i'm doing i'm i'm doing great
it's the best you're my guy
what you think about this [ __ ] you
ain't got all this money that's bruh no
way just blew the [ __ ] up
[ __ ] yo this meant i i turn on netflix i
see this man everywhere that's a good
thing it's an amazing thing it's a good
thing i'm a hard worker man i see hard
hard-working blessed sweat and tears
into this crap very very fortunate to uh
have seen the things that i've seen and
and to still be here this 15 minutes of
fame has lasted for quite some time
15 minutes is forever yeah exactly like
julius caesar didn't say 365 days a year
how old would you be he's only 70 years
before
jesus christ so how old would you be if
he didn't say we were 300 265 days with
a year it's a good question mike and
i'll be honest with you i'm confused
right i think i think this is going to
be one of those things where i just got
to be honest the whole way through right
like you just gotta you gotta just guys
rip it like a band-aid just a guy he's
he's only 70 years before jesus he's
gonna tell us and he just went with it
too so he's gonna tell us this is how
old we are yeah see that's what i'm
saying that's that's what i don't
understand who the hell is this guy this
guy the dictator guy with the
megalomaniac and he told us how old we
were that's our father did you see this
everybody's father he told us how we
were i'm just not good with numbers bash
so like when you do the 365 and then you
do the 70 before and then he goes well
how old were you i'm like 15. maybe 15
minutes it might be forever yeah you
know i think the answer is subjective
you know uh it's good like i said you
know what i'm saying i see what you did
that's good answer subjective but
but mike can we talk about this
transformation picture real quick nah
[ __ ]
listen
you had um stem cell [ __ ] right
stem cell
i've never done nothing man i can turn
it on and off i'm gonna understand hey i
believe you yeah no i believe i know you
don't mind no i do cause you play with
all those guys that do this and you
think you know how you look
this is why i believe it mike i actually
watched your documentary thank you man i
think i think it's dope because
hey tell me about this [ __ ]
documentary don't [ __ ] this up it's
called don't [ __ ] this up it's on
netflix uh and what i did was i pulled
the curtain back on the real the real
side of life in the career so as i was
going through
a bunch of [ __ ] you got to kind of see
the uh the honesty the transparency in
me my team and how we dealt with what
would provided itself to be like one of
the craziest times for me in my career
but it's it's real it's a real moment
real thing camera very very good shouts
out to netflix for allowing me doing it
uh netflix heartbeat productions my
producing team great partners yeah
there's no it's never a you thing it's a
it's i believe in the wii the wii factor
so because of the wii component uh came
out very well man that's facts no it was
very motivating and i saw that you get
up early and work out every day 5 a.m
guy with your boy boss yeah yeah right
still around yeah yeah yeah 5 a.m every
day man early rising you still get up
early mike yeah what time you get up um
i get up around four in the morning in
the morning i don't start running and
stuff till like five five three would
you get up double yeah that's about to
wake up i ride the bike and do the
treadmill first then i go out see once
you adapt to that lifestyle it doesn't
yeah it doesn't go anywhere so sure
you're talking about
if you don't do that you i'm not a nice
person if i don't get that at yeah same
everybody in my house is going through
hell they're getting it if i don't get
that yellow wow
same same it has it has a real effect on
me my day like right now
i got a
i got a nerve i don't know what's going
on like a little pinched nerves i've
i've been down for like four weeks and
you are
you are different because even i'm
getting up i'm going in there i'm
walking on the treadmill walking on the
incline doing a stairmaster i'm not
doing the same that same regimen that
keeps you well you know that's how god
humbles us yeah yeah you know we think
we're in the world oh you know he got me
a
lot of time look at humble facts yeah
big time body start body start breaking
down you think that uh you think this
[ __ ] can kind of last forever that's a
very humbling side of life when that
when that body starts talking to you
differently you're gonna lift up an arm
oh [ __ ]
hey hold on what the [ __ ] is that
nah y'all gotta tell me i know trust me
i mean how do you so me i'm torturing
you he's a young ass [ __ ] young
mother [ __ ] he's a young [ __ ]
man i just got pec surgery god [ __ ]
what man what picture you ain't get no
godzilla where i gotta play
what happened i know that's nothing
happening so after detroit lions week
seven sac jared golf
five tackles of sack qb hit ballin okay
i'm gonna put came up to put my hand in
the huddle
i was like oh damn oh wait what the hell
what's going on got mri boom not the
hand in the huddle
no it wasn't the attacker wasn't got it
yeah i got it i don't trust me i know
about me you good i'm good oh
medic exactly so but i know all about it
no that's fast how long you been down uh
i've been down for
she i was out week seven so like two
months now the craziest thing is there's
no stem y'all don't do that [ __ ]
come on give me true yeah y'all gotta do
stem sir first of all some dudes do
something
okay blood spinning you don't do blood
spinning
if you didn't do that yeah well you know
how do you play how do you play sports
without doing that stuff not everybody
does that i can tell you how what's that
thing called oh the rules there it is i
i just don't know how i just don't know
how to move if you don't get enough
touchdown you're going to be fighting
[ __ ] yeah i actually i sack the qb so i
try to say qb hit people you know so
what is the thing the thing with stem's
uh is supposed to weigh it's supposed to
reduce
rejuvenation take your blood out spin it
right back in yeah is it is it
considered it's considered
like it's it's considered natural or an
unnatural thing i don't really naturally
[ __ ] going back in you that's all
natural
it's rejuvenation but in the world but
in the world of sports i'm saying is
that allowed because it can't be allowed
how could that be illegal i don't know
you're taking your blood spinning it
real fast where it gets really light and
thin and hitting you back and what is
that that's you going in you all right i
don't know right no it's true
right but i don't know listen i'm not
going to speak what does this spin down
to the blood what does the spin does
i think what it does it it uh
i honestly don't know i can't say i'm a
doctor but i know it helps speed it it
has to do something it has to do
something yes it has to speed up the
process
and and repair whatever the damage
the damage parts to the to the muscles
that are torn tendons probably down
that's that's what it has to do
i don't know i i don't i don't i don't
do another [ __ ] that should scare me
that's any anything where you where
you're like putting [ __ ] in your body to
enhance or that scares me yeah
especially
i'm not in the world where i need it so
as a guy that's just trying to
stay in shape to live and be healthy you
know i'm not looking for size i'm not
looking for the added world of cuts and
to where i feel like i gotta let me take
it so i can look better and i gotta be
bigger um it doesn't only it doesn't
only help your body it helps your mind
helps you think better
but i get the same thing out of just
getting up and going if if there was a
lack of
that i'm getting out of what i'm putting
into my days or when i'm putting into
working on myself if i felt like i'm
missing something and i felt like
there's a need for more then it would be
different but i've never had the feeling
of needing more i feel like i'm getting
it all
from doing what i've done um i don't
think we have no idea what we need
no no no i just told you mike i kind of
kind of
i kind of know like i feel like tell me
what i feel like
i feel like i kind of know mike that's
what i'm saying like when i get up in
the morning i'm like yeah i'm gonna go
run and then i run and then like there's
a point where i like the door friends
the dog
i'm like man that feels good like i did
it and i'm like i don't i don't need to
go further than that like you know some
people like
let's keep going keep going let's go
more miles i'm like nah that's it for me
today
i kind of feel like i'm i kind of feel
like i'm maxed out that's an over me
though
that's good like you know right now my
new [ __ ] that i pick up i'm uh i'm a i'm
a i'm a junkie for like new new hobbies
or or the new things so my friends are
now cycling so they say kev you got to
get into cycling you got to start road
biking with us now when i do something i
got to get you in a jet suit a jets okay
come on man
i'm the guy that if you tell me and i
say all right let's do it i'm gonna
figure it out so i i went figured out
the whole world of road biking the i
wanted to clip in got the shoes
you know figured out the proper way to
do it got proton i got uh i have a
peloton bike in a house but you know i'm
more of a rower in a house i do uh hydro
in the road machine when i'm home but on
an actual road bike you know i was like
all right [ __ ] i'm gonna do it let me
see it yeah they got out there and one
day they were like we're gonna go 20
miles
just getting into it it was great
that that another time we went out there
was like hey
yo today we're gonna go 30 miles that's
around 30 miles a couple hills these
hills improve these hills the distance
not but the hills the hills are changing
right
the hills aren't the same like this is
this just starting to hurt all right
like okay they was like yo today let's
do a 70-mile ride i was like no i'm not
gonna do it and it's like wow i said
because 30 miles i felt like was enough
for me it was like but today we're gonna
do seven days like
i've i've reached my math yeah i'm good
at knowing where my max is wow that's
awesome that's especially true that is a
special treat to know yourself you got
to you got to know you got to know your
cut off and that don't mean you don't
challenge yourself just know you're
comfortable and uncomfortable i don't i
don't like i don't like discomfort
that's that's just not for me that
doesn't have a reason or purpose behind
it sure that's that's my release i agree
so when i talk about getting up and
doing all that [ __ ] and not pushing my
body i don't want the discomfort that
could come with something that i've
never been uncomfortable from yeah all
right next little mind [ __ ] moment that
i gave you all right no it's not perfect
you just don't want to hold on expand
yourself you're happy right here you're
happy you're happy right here yeah
no i can relate to that definitely when
i train like i hate doing stuff that
doesn't translate everything i train has
to kind of translate to my sport and
what i do for a profession that makes
sense i don't i'm not going to do
nothing past that or anything ridiculous
you know mike it's like when you train
for when you boxed right yes yeah so
when you want to go a little insane you
just go a little bit further yeah it's a
little bit but you don't go crazy you
don't like you said you don't go 70. you
don't go yeah i mean you know man me and
my trainer have had it out you know
there's been times when he was like yo
let's let's put more on there max out
and i was like for what
he was like let's see what we can get
why that's like
i feel like i'm already there come on
man let's go for higher i was like what
if i hurt myself no exactly he's like
but what if you don't i don't know i
kind of okay with not knowing what
happened
i only i think i'm extreme because
you know i look at like this guard gave
me all this and this all i got left like
five miles to get the [ __ ] out of here
well mike you're different you're you're
you're
yeah
look at that i've gotten so much
i mean your level of competitive with
you just with you and self and this is
from talking to you is it's pretty
[ __ ] amazing just to hear you break
down
how you still approach [ __ ] like you
still getting up in the morning you
still
working out like you that's a different
mind you gotta you gotta there's a
difference
because they keep offering me money to
do this [ __ ] did you say that
yeah i'm like saying that like you ain't
gonna really do this you stop [ __ ]
right that was just good you know where
he started some [ __ ] still yeah i'm like
[ __ ]
there's not many that i can at this my
kids are saying no don't stop that you
get your old ass there
but i think hey y'all guys gonna be
surprised when i you get your [ __ ]
percentage huh
they don't want me to do it now huh yeah
you'd be surprised how happy you'd be
surprised that i think the biggest the
biggest thing that i take away from mike
is like you know
the the ability just to keep it together
right like after a certain age you look
at a lot of your athletic heroes a lot
of these you know these these goats and
you know after a certain age they just
start to
start to break down fall apart you know
not might take long [ __ ] asses
be on their neck left over
that was me too because um i had a
hoverboard with hoverboard i fell about
some
bulging discs just [ __ ] me all up
couldn't do anything then i caught
sciatica i was like i was in the
wheelchair that was the only time i'm
happy to be in the wheelchair because i
go by everybody first class and
everything yeah
there's a wheelchair veteran's gym so
i'm always happy to be in the wheelchair
but i can't [ __ ] walk
that's what but you like but you got
away from that that time like you got
back to
you got back like well absolutely you
know when you when you get i did
everything i could do to give it to
myself oh yeah you got [ __ ] blood to
research everything whatever they had to
help me anytime anti-aging whatever it
was i was the guinea pig it was just it
was just it was it was so new they
didn't even know the work i said you let
me try it cuz i was so broken down
you know now i'm fighting people again
not like look i'm old no i'm not old but
i'm an interesting guy because i'm doing
this stuff huh howdy mike i'm 55 god
damn it
[ __ ]
yeah i still do this [ __ ] 55 years old
i'm 42. that's stupid i mean i consider
that i don't say that old 55 no no dude
it was 20 years ago mike mike wasn't
right here in front of me i would tell
you that's old 20 years ago that was
earlier yeah i feel like old now is like
60. oh but 25 right there i agree 20
i agree 20 years ago 55 was old most
people that was born in 1927 died when
they were 55. as you get as you get
older
your respect and appreciation for
different ages change mm-hmm right so
42 yeah
i don't think 42 and 40 is old anymore
but when i was 25 you still looking at
it like damn damn that's old yeah now
you're 42 now right about 42 now like
eight years from now you're gonna start
working on a relationship with god
all right all right no no it's going to
be really serious stuff let's go get
some more seriously oh yeah yeah
you do i'll tell you i'll tell you what
changed at 42. the way that the way that
you look
you start to dissect all of the things
that you've done differently
so your past life choices your past
rights and wrongs you start to question
the reason
and the why yeah and as you progress in
life there's a constant debate of what
you're doing and if you're doing the
things that are right what what's how
how do you see me how am i seeing myself
am i
am i a good person yeah what makes me a
good person like am i
you're your own judge you're your own
jury you're your own execution
you know who you are and we can't tell
you because you know who you are i i
will agree but then at the same time you
still you still aren't free from the
moments of questioning some of your past
decisions no the things that you've done
but you know sometimes that's not that's
our shadow our shadow is what does
something our conscience never want us
to be aware of we don't know we we have
we all have that shadow that we hide
from everybody
and we have to get our ego to have a
relationship with that our ego is so
afraid of our shadow you feel like you
got an ego
oh i mean i feel like in my profession
you got to have an ego right you got to
like anything and anything and anything
in life if you want to be great at
something or you want to you know hit
the pinnacle that's what some people say
some people egos um they come in
different um
it's coming they just come in different
packages like somebody's eagle could be
just
very humble brother thank you it was a
wonderful match better look next time
thank you your parents are wonderful
parents and that's the ego too just to
be humble to people yeah because i'm
better you know it's still the ego it's
still that eagle i'm better but you know
just some people are loud i'm loud with
mine
some people everybody has a different
show that's facts i i i think that it
comes with
i don't know i get i get weird when the
conversation of ego comes because
there's a there's a there's a high level
of confidence that comes with
knowing that you do the thing that you
chose to do
right or at a high level right and if i
if i know that
well my confidence will sometimes
transfer to those that don't have the
confidence or the ability to do as an
ego yeah and it's it's in some ways it
shapes the form it's a fine it's a fine
line it's not like it's but it comes
into question
only when there's people
that don't do the thing or that are
looking from the outside at the thing
everybody's got the right answers about
the things that they do we believe our
you know the straight direction of god
we believe our ego comes straight from
god that information comes straight for
god that's what our ego believes
oh i see you're saying that that the
the the the tone and the intent behind
this is a god given talent this is me
yeah that's interesting and i also see
what you're saying where
it's kind of like when people try to
give you advice but they're not in your
shoes right they're not kevin hart no
they're not super famous super you know
successful they're trying to tell you
how to do something that they've never
had or never done or dealt with you're
you're in a very small percentage yeah
of of
personnel when you get to a certain
place it's a it's a very small group of
people that can understand and identify
with the
the road that you're walking down right
so um it's very easy for other people to
look from the outside
and and make decisions of what's going
on in that snow globe oh man no you
can't do you gotta you there's no way
but
no one really understands the true
pressure that comes with
the life of being committed of of
success and i'm not talking about so
many people think it's just fame right
let's take the fame part out of it all
right [ __ ] the fame [ __ ] the attention
it's the
expectation and want to consistently be
where you are that's that's the biggest
piece of pressure biggest piece of
pressure comes with oh [ __ ] i got here
oh [ __ ] i i tasted this oh wow
i like this i want to stay up here now
i don't want to
i don't want to leave here all right
that's the biggest mind [ __ ] because
what does that do to the person so now
that you're here well now you're working
to stay here but now your dips and
valleys well the biggest effect
is on is on you
people don't know what that does to the
person what does that do to that
person's psyche so when you look at a
lot of people in these positions and
those those [ __ ] dips and those mind
mind-blowing moments of what seems to be
breakdowns is not it's dealing with life
in ways that you didn't know it would be
after you never knew it would exist that
way never knew it's real the hardest
thing to tell somebody that succeeds is
that yo this is gonna this is gonna
change get the [ __ ] out of here
i'm the [ __ ] i'm what
what
money i
be patient save your money nobody wants
to hear that [ __ ] when they when they
fly in because you don't think that that
flight is going to end the reality of a
flight and plane leveling out
well that only comes in some of the most
unexpected times and moments where
people have to sit in that and process
it differently
so that within itself is a talent yeah
to process that [ __ ] is a talent to be
able to go oh okay
oh this is different
oh this can be life as i now should know
it or do i gotta dig deeper do i gotta
figure it out again oh wow i gotta i
gotta rework and i gotta get to another
area of success to find that same joy
that i had when i was at this level
success oh i got to open up different
doors oh i can't just be
satisfied with this one door not because
of the fame that came with it i need
other outlets so i can feel creative so
i can feel productive how do you feel
about what's more energy what do you
want those people to give you it seems
like you want them to give you something
i don't need anything from people
i need something i need something from
myself of knowing that i'm still
applying myself
people can't give me nothing because i
feel like you've given me
the the
you've given me the bonus
of
a start
middle i don't want to say end because
i'm not done but without the support you
don't get to these these stages so from
people i can't ask for anything else you
don't you don't need to give me anything
else at this point
i have to get things for myself
because i still have to get excited
about what i do yeah i still got to find
new things to create i still got to find
new things to [ __ ] get up and get out
to bed with i still got to find a reason
to go i love my job
when you look up 20 years you're doing
the same thing anybody will get jaded
anybody will [ __ ] get tired so how do
i not get tired yeah all right well
that's you sitting down with yourself
and your mind and your [ __ ] bubble
with nobody else around saying well what
else can i do
that's when the world of doors should
open up so you know when i look at my
career when you look at business you
look at stand-up comedy you look at
acting you look at writing producing you
know these aren't things that uh i
created these are portals that have
always been there i just wanted to knock
on the doors and see if i could if i
could go through and have success too
arthur uh journalism i mean you can go
you can go down on the line what is
success to you brother
success to me
success to me is
making the dream that most don't think
is achievable
realistic
success is
amplifying
that young black kid that has no idea
what grass in front of a house looks
like or behind the house
where the airplane looks like what
another country looks like to understand
that there's a time in everyone's life
when they will be able to go fulfill
the dream to travel the dream to be
successful the dream to apply yourself
educate whatever there is a lack of
understanding
that we can go get what we want
right and it's a it's a it's a real
thing of i wish i could not saying that
everybody's opportunities are the same
but we got examples of people who did go
and get it out the mud
those examples should mean more
so for me
if and when said goals are achieved
little black boy little black girl
that comes and lived in the same
environment
that was used to the same things that i
was used to
well that ambition to get up go to
school listen apply it kind of changes
right yeah so
that's that's what drives what drives is
when you go back to philadelphia i go
meet some kids and they shake my hand
and i'm real
i'm no longer i'm no longer fiction
you're real yeah you know so i i can
remember i can remember those hands that
i shook
when
things started to change for me and i
was so [ __ ] blown away that the
person was real cause you don't believe
it
say what you want i never saw michael
jackson in person
i never shook michael's hand
i never got to see michael talk as a
regular person
so michael jackson is still michael
jackson you're not he's still oh my god
but think about the people that got to
be in that room with mike
and and talk think about the people that
actually had access to michael jordan
and they just like us michael [ __ ]
jackson that's absolutely absolutely but
your but your your grasp of
success in the what behind it changes
when you can go that [ __ ] is
real yeah like i'm kevin hart here and
i'm sitting next to him to mike tyson
yeah that's facts mike tyson is [ __ ]
real you get to shake his hand yeah i
shook his hand i talked to mike and yeah
and mike goes through all of his ups and
downs in life but you go he's real
people come from from my real situation
oh listen i had like oh [ __ ] i had a
great rehab career
oh
oh i had a great rehab that's where we
battled we battled in this we had a long
conversation before and mike loves to
speak a certain way and i'm like
you know
from this side looking in
i am a student of
those that have kicked open different
doors so you know the legend that's
attached to your name
is what i will forever see you as an ad
what i respect the legend of you even
more for
is the truth and transparency that you
put on display
through your [ __ ] life once again it
goes back to what i was just saying
that's the real yeah
how many people
identify with the real there's so many
there's so many and i feel like that's
the that's the book of information
that's the pamphlet that's the that's
the thing
that we that we don't highlight enough
you know um
it's one thing about my ego my ego and
my shadow get along
okay my shadow don't defend my [ __ ]
ego
and that's cool
i don't i don't i've never i've never
had the the shadow problem no the shadow
is a shame that no one knows but you
okay well i do have that there's stuff
you don't want no one gonna know
everyone does that
if then if you think if they knew what
you knew but they knew what you thought
about you your age they wouldn't like
you no more yeah that's a shadow okay
then that that makes a different level
of sense yeah yeah yeah
imagine that being cool with your ego
yeah that and your ego being cool
and your ego is to boost you up and this
guy they let you know hey you ain't sure
you really like this and you know i know
they don't know but i know you really
like this
those conversations with yourself can
get yeah the shadow yeah
the shadow so in the collective
consciousness
how was it at first like
i feel like as an athlete right as an
athlete you know you've done something
like especially when you hear your name
used in a rap song
like when you first heard your name mike
i know you probably you had i know both
of y'all have multiple songs multiple
lyrics with your name in it like where
were y'all like first when you first
heard it like what did you think like
was that your moment you were like oh
wow like i'm actually like doing
something like um it's been it's been a
couple those are just i think those are
always nods of
nods of like uh
respect or
or love
from from your counterparts like whether
we realize it or not um we're all
in entertainment in some way shape or
form what we do
is
for the sole purpose of entertaining
uh on some level to the world right so
um whether you're an athlete rapper
singer
comedian
uh author you know host whatever it is
we we provide a sense of entertainment
so um as a collective when you can show
that love in some way
i just think that's dope as hell so it
was always one where you know it's
humbling yeah but it's also
you know it's it's like [ __ ] man damn
that's dope yeah
it's a good [ __ ] feeling about you
mike sometimes i'm a little ashamed but
cause um
i know my shadow my shadow doesn't
deserve what my consciousness receives
so i look at it funny
wow
i never thought about it mike say [ __ ]
like that you just gotta just look at it
for a while just wait for for it to die
down and then be like yeah
all right that's what i'll be telling
you that's really
you just make sure you hear it but
i know that's right
or you go like
cool
right that way that way because if he's
not done he go
[ __ ]
they haunt you it's what haunts you
what's make you f afraid of succeeding i
like that i like your comparison with
the shadow and that yeah though i i
definitely like that the eagle wants you
to be great but the shadow knows your
your weakest spots that
what you're ashamed of
your big your biggest struggles they
come from you
come from there they come from your
battles with yourself so exactly what
he's saying about the shadow and the
shadow checking the ego and the ego
checking the shot like it's a battle
with you yeah if this pandemic showed us
nothing else it showed us you know how
much
people are battling with that that
concept of because people are dying in a
real catastrophic moment uh and that
we're all witnessing so when you see how
many different people are handling it
differently and just i'm telling you
that conversation with yourself
hopefully hopefully we're we're on the
back half of it though for sure
hopefully definitely definitely yeah i
mean i'm back to doing
live shows which i want to do that i
miss my show my one-minute show i i'm
back to doing live shows
about to go on tour soon um
you know i probably announce
a tour of schedule but i can say going
back on stage yeah being in front of
live people yeah it's getting nothing
like that's not nothing being the best
actor in the world on the screen there's
nothing like nothing like that
isn't playing no no because the people
tell you what they want you to give them
it's just like everything you say is
wrong because you can't feel them
telling you say this say that well the
craziest part is that you realize
you realize that
you pot there was a chance that you may
not
have respected
the true value of what you had yeah
because it was there so there was a
there was an expectation that this thing
is going to last forever right that's
almost what we were talking about
earlier like there's this thing that's
like oh my god this is dope as hell yeah
that's what it's going to be and when it
was taken away
by the way you didn't believe that they
could take it away this [ __ ] has
happened here but i got shows no we're
shutting it down
yeah but i got to go to another city
they shouldn't down here but no we're
shutting everything down
there's no no more that's right there's
an effect going on now no more no more
interaction no more handshaking no more
uh buildings with personnel where you're
just speaking to strangers you can't
even see a simple hello cause people
have the mask when it first started
people were in the house skating and
weighed like a mother scared this [ __ ]
think about it we at that point you you
listening to so much different [ __ ] you
don't know what to think but when you
get back out
and you saw your first person shook your
first hand
that you received it a different way you
got a hello again you've seen the way
when i went out on stage and i saw some
on my guys cheers i respected a
different way my thank you had a
different meaning my i love you had a
different meaning because [ __ ] if it
gets taken away again
know that this time i want you to feel
the appreciation because i don't know if
i made you feel it
and and it's and it's proper and it's
proper meaning and and and display from
me to you that's real that's the dopest
thing about going back out and that's
the that's the biggest hope of wanting
to get back to the place of where we are
i mean i feel like especially now people
we [ __ ] need it that's why so much
so much this [ __ ] we we not we're not
interacting yeah we don't see each other
enough now so we get out we shocked
that's why you got bigger race reactions
now oh my god what's that black guy
doing
oh my god look at that [ __ ] white
well hey man you we so shocked because
we just now are getting comfortable with
getting back around one another so don't
think for a second
that that interaction that we once had
of community of just being around each
other don't think for a second
that that doesn't serve an important
purpose in our [ __ ] day to day
because it does i'm just sure that um
cooper has a lot to do with um our
conduct socially absolutely yeah
absolutely
it's another added component
for a conversation of
and i hate to say it hate what you don't
want to say you know
mike what the [ __ ] is that is that
mushroom oh jesus oh god i thought mike
just ate a bowl of mushroom
oh my god i almost [ __ ] on myself
oh i thought he took the whole [ __ ]
thing
mike you can't do that
guys
stop the podcast
we got to get mike to the hospital
it was blackberries it was black bears
everybody calm down
oh did you see me panic just now oh god
i just don't want to do that and turn
around and i'm somebody else
you see somebody else's face if you were
somebody else you'd be god
hey
he's only just on him
infused with heaven
oh my god it might turn around and just
start talking to me like somebody else
like it's me mike it's kind of he don't
see that
oh we gotta run that's what i told you i
was gonna sit there for a second you
want to sit there brother it's just how
i get room second you're second party i
gotta
so uh how do you keep yourself from not
getting burned out i love him this guy
for a [ __ ] host because when i blank
out boom he comes out with some good
white [ __ ]
he called it good ones why did he why
didn't you why did you [ __ ] leave him
how come he had to play football mike
[ __ ]
that season we're in a season man if you
just had to go play football mike that's
his
just his job you know
i think it's stupid too mike you know
it's it's it's dumb mike but he uh he's
got to do it they just got to uh what
they call those things contracts there
it is
uh how do you how do you keep yourself
from not getting burnt out cause you
work your ass off i think i can burn
that [ __ ]
the world of build is better right like
if you if you have people around you
that believe in the vision
of
building this one brick into a empire uh
that becomes the hobby that becomes
that's what my wife does she's got all
these [ __ ] houses all over the place
written them out to people and she's
something i'm a real fly i want myself i
want to keep and i want to rent them out
to people i mean that's smart that's
brilliant that's that's bricks on bricks
i'm a fan of it um and i don't think you
get tired of doing it creating success
not just for yourself but for others
that's a that's a priority so um
heartbeat what i want that to be what i
want it to become
that's uh that's the reason for me
putting so much
into that engine and you know when it's
time for that engine to slow down and
going to cruise control
the thing that we worked hard to build
that'll still be able to go yeah it's
going so fast so fast so fast just so
you can remove yourself and cruise and
that thing goes with it without you
that's fair that's that's that's dope
how does your comedy like
change now since the beginning like what
is this one the special that i'm doing
now or working on now this tour this is
the one that i really had to change this
is the one where it's like
all right let me let me
let me really put some [ __ ] together
to
to just
to to
tone down the conversations right here's
the good and the bad the good and the
bad about me is i'm a brand uh that
brand is attached to
a universal appeal family
kids uh household
uh
marriage there's so much attached to the
conversation so my comedy has always
been in that space right and the reason
why is because that's where my life
that's where my [ __ ] went yeah you know
once you get to a certain point you lose
the edge that you once had because
you're not doing the same [ __ ] you're
not you're not i'm not going to the club
i'm not out in the streets i'm not i'm
not a part of the the energy that that
that young
youthful generation has i'm in a house
so all you know i feel that the house
you know
you know wife you know kids i know you
watch tv i know there's taco night i
know that's it
so on this one i said let me go and
live a little let me go and change the
mindset up and i'm gonna remove the
family from this one so this is more
about um
you know it's more about
life
life through a different lens than what
i've shown for a while but also just to
just give people a punch in the back of
the head of you know don't forget that
this is
this is what i do what do you think
about money
what i think about money uh-huh
uh money's nice but does it control me
no
but do you have to get there to
understand that i mean that's your
opinion of that
not dissecting your opinion of it i
think that there is a
value
in money
i think that you know a lot of things in
life
that you kind of need to see
to realize that you don't
need money presents that
um
you can't get a respect for a different
meaning of happiness without seeing a
superficial side
to what you think
happiness is attached to
but you need the money to see and get
that example so i can't [ __ ] on it and
go oh man [ __ ] that money ain't poor i
can't do that yeah because
without
having the money i wouldn't have got
those lessons but i will say that it
doesn't
it doesn't run me it doesn't
move me i mean i turn down
significant amounts of money but only
because i can yeah if i couldn't
i couldn't you know there was moments in
early parts of my career where
the shows and movies that i did was some
of the worst [ __ ] ever but i had to get
do you look at your money as being um
something that um
it should be inherited in the family and
stuff like that um
it's a good question mike i think that
i'm gonna keep a line of
from your from your generation and your
bloodline on now we're gonna be knowing
there's people that taking care have
money you do want to change the
narrative attached
to your family and to you i'm talking
about yourself to myself i'm poor and
listen i want my family to be known that
they've never been poor because i a
little insecurity i i don't want nobody
to ever be like me
and the way i was that kind of stuff
i want there to be a thing that we built
that lasts that last i want i want there
to be something that has to be worked
that last right
uh am i in a world of everybody's rich
from now on no
um with my kids
and my kids kids if we if we operate
this machine correctly
then we have a funnel
of family wealth generation that can be
obtained but also a concept
of
of life so when you look at some
cultures right some cultures stick
together
and work together uh there's some
families where kids are embedded into
businesses i'll give you an example i
went to
um my wife took me to this this place in
uh utah or a resort right and we go
there and she wanted to do like this
little horseback riding trail we're
going to do the horseback riding trail
and it was two young girls that had the
horses
that were taking us on the tour wow and
i asked the young girls i'm like how do
y'all and one girl was 15 the other was
17. and they get to talking to me and
it's a family business their family
uh
buys horses breeds horses
raises horses and throughout this area
or this
radius
they're responsible for providing horses
horse tours etc they got a family of
like six
and all of the kids are teenagers and
some young adults but in this family
business
the young kids understand that this is
what we do
the older side are only teaching their
kids and their kids are embracing this
thing now this thing is all they know
but this is life this is money this is
this is comfort but it was embedded from
the ground up
i don't like the idea of
you're on your own you're on your own
you're on your own without a concept of
what we can do
so in this thing that i'm building
there's room for everybody to succeed
everybody can pick a trait everybody can
pick their space of love and talent it
doesn't have to be one thing but this
portal
provides a entry and an exit for you all
so it's my job
as the
parent and the discovery
to educate and try to make you
understand
so that we don't fall into the same
the same line yeah that we've been so
comfortable with falling back into
if done correctly well it's a lesson
that i'm giving and then one that you're
re-giving and that we'll give for a long
time
and we'll have a lot of respect and
you'll follow the lead of so many that
have done it i think i'm envious when
you go to a place and it's a family
a family business
when you go to a hotel and it's a family
and then you meet the son the daughter
the aunt the and everybody's embedded
like i'm envious of that and you know at
times it's like well [ __ ] why don't why
don't we have more of us in that same
conversation and those of us that are
well they're not highlighted enough yeah
you know you got a lot of restaurants in
the south that are family owned and
family-run but they aren't but they're
not hotliners right those are those are
people that are coming up inside of a of
a business inside of a pipeline and then
you got this too
you got guys like the gucci killing
people and
ruining people's lives and stuff all
family and not good family that's true
you know i mean especially when it comes
to corporate that's true you saw the
movie about the gucci and all that oh
yeah uh that's true the new the new
movie yeah
that was so crazy to see that stuff i
mean that's corporate america though
yeah no that's that's that's that's
family
that too oh all family ain't good family
yeah that's fine all family isn't going
to be sometimes we have to make our own
family because all family is not good
family yeah but key word is when you say
make your own family i think that comes
with
investing in people that are investing
in your vision which i believe in as
well yeah absolutely right it's not all
it's not all going to be blood and all
blood ain't going to be great blood nope
but you still creating opportunities
for your own and for others if you can
i i take priority in it you know that's
once again where we're talking about
finding new
reasons for
energy or you know excitement and
getting up in the morning those things
everything that um inspires us have a
dark side absolutely everything love
everything at the dark side absolutely
we're capable and respectful to the dark
side willing to accept the dark side
like with the good side then we're cool
well they it ain't all gonna be good
that's one of the biggest things i tell
my kids like if if life was only
supposed to be good then that means it's
perfect and in a perfect life isn't a
good life like no such thing no there's
no education they did a study with these
rats it was like a rat utopia they had
more land more food than they could ever
have
and they had no problem with life and
you know what they started doing they
started breaking off and and pat and
couples
they have the aggressive ones here they
have the pastor's ones here and then
they have these guys that just kept
looking flat clean and then they but
they were aggressive too don't [ __ ] me
but they were very good looking
and so everybody started attacking them
raping them they started doing a whole
bunch of stuff and then eventually they
all started dying out
so you're saying oh sorry he's saying
that we're right i'm saying this with
yes he's all wrapped i'm saying without
struggle there's no progress we can't
have no free meal
this world is not made out of a free
meal
it's all about struggle
you know it is if they i i've said this
before in other interviews and i mean it
if you really really look at the game of
monopoly
it has so many different meanings
yeah it has so many different meanings
and i know we play monopoly i know that
we've
uh adapted and uh
adjusted and made rules fit to how we
want to play et cetera but if you look
at
the game of life
and if you look at monopoly
how we have an opportunity and some
people
grasp the opportunity different
some people understand the concept
different and are able to make these
dollars connected make sense it's a
struggle for some right getting around
that board to succeeding staying out of
trouble uh not having to pay bill i mean
it's so much that you get
that it equates to some of the real life
lessons that you go through and i you
know i don't know if everybody looks at
it the same but i promise you if you
play monopoly play it with a different
intent play it play it with like a real
want
to succeed at the end of the game even
if you don't win
did you succeed were you in the game
yeah or were you at the bottom and if
you were at the bottom
where are you at like is there a synergy
no facts what happened to the person
that's on top
i sometimes look at that person yeah
sometimes look at the person i'm telling
you like we i i look at the game
differently but that person ain't shared
with the people that's not on top of
hitting [ __ ]
well [ __ ] that person well i mean it is
a game it is a game mike so she's
remembered you know [ __ ] that person
all right
of greatness it was my little niece mike
it comes you gotta win regardless you
don't matter that's right
to conquer the old gays
[ __ ] the one guy what happened to the
guy at the top
becomes the idiot
there's a there's a couple people that
i've heard
um give good gems about
you know
some of the best things it's not about
it's not about the money you get
it's about those
that you
showed how to make money
while you
got the money that you were getting like
what's all about knowing who you are
before they tell you who you are before
before
you're saying before it comes before all
of the [ __ ] comes oh absolutely before
before they start to shape form and
opinion yeah of who you are yeah okay
you go for that opinion because it's
better looking than the opinion you have
for yourself so i think i'm gonna go
with this opinion also you know nothing
too it's like
when sometimes it takes somebody forming
an opinion on you for you to realize
that that ain't you
right like that's barracks no sometimes
it takes somebody going oh
oh yeah he's you know what he is he's
the guy he's like wait hold on
no that's not
no that's actually not me and that oh is
that is that what just yeah is that how
people see or view and and then you kind
of understand why it's important to have
a voice why it's important to
to to to speak that voice
um in different times of my life i knew
who i was but if you asked me now who
the person i was at that time of my life
i couldn't tell you
facts
uh 20 22 to 20
20 22 to 32.
a chameleon
trying to blend in yeah trying to figure
out like
the voice the
the purpose the direction you know how
how how is this gonna pan out how am i
piecing this oh they're doing this oh
that's what i need to do
oh okay this will be oh okay that's what
i i'm gonna do that
oh this this is the move no i'm gonna do
it it's that's how that's what a normal
person he gets off the fence and makes
mistakes
some people have some people are garden
some people have a uh
i don't know they have a mention a form
in life they have somebody to guide them
from the day they were born this is what
you're gonna do
if this would be a preacher whatever be
a garbage can collector whatever tennis
player champion this is what you're
going to do
they put you oh they put their they put
your seeds in your own head
do you feel like
do you feel like
when you got older were there were there
lessons from
the parents that kicked in later
like like from absolutely from that
kicked in late like what age were you
when you felt like oh [ __ ]
that's what that was about no
my kids are the same way they're all
polite mm-hmm
you know i'm a pig sometimes but i'm
polite isn't that weird
no no no it is because that's my parents
that's my whole bloodline though the
price the smith polite very polite stuck
with you kids are the same way whatever
yeah they're giving [ __ ] away
i'm uh
respectful
and
i i can say polite uh but extremely
respectful
and aware of how i treat others how you
treat very consciousness you get treated
yeah
that's the thing for my mom that was
extremely important you know you treat
others how you expect to get treated 100
yeah that's the biggest one for me yeah
i remember um in your special you taught
you highlighted your mom and
you want to talk about kind of how big
of an influence she was for you girls
yeah the the influence but once again
the stuff didn't click
until you know my mom wasn't here and
i'm older and i'm processing a lot of
those lessons differently you know what
they're here with us uh no mom passed
away sorry
um
but i can i
i remember
you know that that age where you start
battling right without his mother yeah
every everything is
a challenge i don't want to do that
you're trying to make me do this you're
being too strict you're doing this
that's not who i am or what i don't like
you think you know everything
and
you know some of those moments when my
mom
prohibited me from doing so much
acted as the best decisions because in
that time she made me commit to doing
other things
and anything that i committed to i had
to finish
so one of the biggest things that also
has stuck with me is
whatever you start you have to finish
there is nothing that you can leave and
complete because that means you quit on
it yep so there's nothing that i start
that i don't finish no matter what the
time is in between it no matter how long
whatever i have to finish it
that lesson is with me until this day
but that's the biggest one
that now i'm battling with my kids about
and the confidence is like oh they they
[ __ ] today
but they'll be fine down below down the
line it's gonna click like oh damn oh
wow dad told me that yeah oh [ __ ] didn't
they get me crying
[Applause]
broke my dad i'm sorry i'm sorry my man
but my dad i just i kind of and
especially i he talked about his mother
how much of an influence positive
influence she was
and how strong of a woman she was so i
just had to you know i wanted to ask
about that crazy thing about my mom my
mom
never saw
she never saw him before yeah never my
mom never saw me touch the stage because
she was over religious
so the environments in which comedy
presented itself
they didn't match her religious beliefs
smoking drinking mm-hmm uh it's just too
much right language yeah so
uh after my mom passed away
my brother we're going through like the
the little
i don't even call the basement but our
version of a basement and we find this
box
open the box my mom had clips
clips articles
from all of like my
premature stand-up success wow kevin
hart won a death gym competition
laugh house comedy club uh budding star
amateur night when i got my first sitcom
the big house uh when i when i got my
comedy central special everything that i
was doing i would talk to her about i
never knew that she was watching but you
know we talked we were cool we were
great she was supporting but she had it
all
and she highlighted it her own way i
didn't find until we were gone in a
[ __ ] box she saved everything
everything taped every my my tv show was
only on for six episodes
the only record that i have until
recently i think they put them out on 2b
or something the only record that i had
of my sitcoms with my mom vhs tapes she
taped every episode
so it's the dope [ __ ] that a parent does
that you'll never see
that makes you respect the real
the real side of parenting it's it's
it's the love that they don't show
that makes you go oh [ __ ]
that makes you go oh [ __ ] like you're
always there yeah you were never not
there yeah it's something that you just
you both just said
um that cause you know i'm a younger
dude and now i'm like realizing like
when your mom like telling you advice
and you're like well i'm like why you
know but like it's so true like i'm just
blessed in the fact that
and like i do see now like there's stuff
that she told me that i was always like
like why that it does come up now and
you know like you said as an entertainer
you always got to be careful what you do
what you say and stuff like that and
yeah moms are the best man it's salute
salute and you know i don't i don't [ __ ]
on my dad my dad serves a valuable
purpose i think you know dads get a dad
gets such a hard
a hard rap
just because a mother's love is such a
it's such an overbearing amount of love
and it should be right it should be but
a father
father's [ __ ] valuable man you know
and mistakes flawed and all
my dad has played a significant role
in
me being the man that i am now granted
is there is there's some cobblestone in
there we got some bumpy road in it
absolutely but
the impact that a father has
is is real correct and and it's
necessary and i think you know what's
your relationship with your sister your
brothers for sure me my brother me and
my brother you and him me and my brother
close man my older brother my older
brother
my dad went through his you know his
downs that was my dad and my brother
my dad my my brother is until this day
i i'll give you a fact about my brother
that i love
you know the [ __ ] thing about our
career there's a gift and a curse with
time
right like
the gift is oh my god you're fulfilling
this dream
it's it's what you want to do when
you're going out and you're
accomplishing it you're going to go get
it but it takes your time
so that time you you're not there yeah
right
my brother
tag
he's there my brother is the
the uncle of all uncles there's there's
nothing that my kids
have not done haven't experienced uh kev
we i'm teaching how to ride a bike when
you come home they're gonna show you we
all riding bikes together i love it i
get home dad let me show you the moments
he makes sure that energy
has always been there for me he's
the kind stupid [ __ ] you don't even
think about yeah he uh you know this is
two years ago
i'm 40. [ __ ] we don't want to cry on
the [ __ ] show i gotta tell you these
stories [ __ ] it out these are real
stories yo he's a real estate yeah
potatoes
tell me this doesn't blow you i promise
this blows your mind
a kite it's better than that a kite
right
something as simple as a kite yeah when
i was a kid i don't know maybe i flew a
kite i don't [ __ ] know it's not a toy
this time this generation
generation is all electronics facts
right all the games whatever
my brother goes kev i'm coming out there
i got kites
i'm gonna teach them
how to fly these kites man we're gonna
go out there they're gonna love it and i
got boomerangs not this ain't nothing
groundbreaking
saying nothing ground they little nerf
boomerangs
we go out to a [ __ ] park
kids throwing the boomerangs running
around with the kites and i look
and i go
i never would have did that
not because i
i'm dumb and i don't know how i don't
think like i would never go with kite no
i don't think like
i don't think i said hey let's play
sports or something yeah
i don't i don't think like that yeah but
it makes you realize the importance of
having
a partner
the importance of having that that ride
or die
that's with you who says i'm invested
and not just you
but the kid so my brother's life now is
an uncle
he's devoted to them kids it don't
matter what it is my brother is i'm
coming i'm with them
hey man i'm with the little ones we
gonna do this the old movies that you
don't think about
hey we watching the rad schools we i
want them to know i don't think about
that [ __ ] yeah but the fact that these
are moments that he creates and i get to
doing with my kids it just shows why you
need that yin and yang
you know it's it doesn't take one it
takes a village sometimes and you know
the things that i feel like we didn't
get from my dad hey come on we're doing
this two miles today come on
come on
put your sneakers on are you [ __ ]
around that's me
no i don't know that [ __ ] around
without a hand on the bike no no no no
no no yeah come on guys that's the way i
come on guys
what are we doing dad we're going to the
gym we're going to
but that's the difference yeah on the
other side my brother's never doing that
yeah he's never doing that i'm the guys
all right come on man hey go read the
book give me my reports what'd you read
no the grandparents were laughing and
playing with them all day
i'm like hey come on let's do these
push-ups come on come on man i'm the
same you're running this treadmill or
not man just give me 30 minutes all
right same thing else i've built from 12
to 30. you cut it down yeah yeah
saturday just give me give me a quick
30. yeah you're good i promise i'm gonna
leave you alone for the rest of the day
i'm the same way come on guys
i think i'm the only guy that does that
well my daughter my daughter has faked
the injury on me somebody said dad i
can't my knee i told you
let's walk something down
i already know when i have kids i don't
be the same exactly but but that's the
side of being active yeah that's not
it's not the side of being crazy like
you want them to be active yeah it's
today's time like hey the one thing that
the one thing that i do
that i do wish
that there was a a bigger presence of
my kids don't have the neighborhood um
and
you know we
in our culture
we we embrace this [ __ ] thing we
can't have our children that's putting
our children in fear we can't we worry
if they go down the street to the store
they can't do that they'll be hey go to
the store and give me some stuff i have
the name they don't have that no no i
have the neighborhood and that's the
that's the one thing everybody knows
everybody everybody knows everybody's
business
everybody loves everybody even though we
fight among each other we all fight we
all battle but that neighborhood that
neighborhood builds character mm-hmm
that environment
it it it does something to to personnel
those kids get experiences growing up oh
my god we walked down here such and such
did this i'm going over sunshine it was
always some lost art
[ __ ] on the corner
you'll never see that again people on
the corner hey entire neighborhood irish
there's people on the corner talking
[ __ ] whatever it may be
talking whatever whatever happened last
year down there he came out of jail he
just got locked up he got killed last
night those are the those are the [ __ ]
looking for him we know i made that
corner you truly you truly
if and when removed you you understand
the value of it that's why i never frown
upon it i never look down on i i embrace
that world of community that that
neighborhood that that thing that thing
is a character within itself it's a
person yeah and that person
that person is building so much
character into those people and that's
that's one thing
that you know i know that my kids just
will never and it's not their fault
right they were born into something
different but that they'll never had
that they'll never experience that so
even when i take them home to go see it
they're so hyped to see it but they
still don't understand it yeah because
it didn't happen you don't understand it
yeah they weren't hanging i mean they'll
never know what it's like to go to the
[ __ ] corner store like he said and go
get the [ __ ] and come back and bring the
wrong chain
oh my god i owe you right i owe you
mother tell pat i give to him next time
neighborhood ass whoopings when
everybody whipped your ass cause your
mom wasn't home i used to get them i can
memory lane of that uh it's something
that just now
you once again this is you turning into
the older guy as you get older you look
you look back on those times man but i
will say shout out to nancy hart r.i.p
one of the best ever do it and shout out
to my dad you know fathers get [ __ ] on
not mine even though i talk about you a
lot dad i love you and you know uh i do
i talk about my dad a whole lot i'll be
[ __ ] killing my dad but
they deserve it sometimes that's what it
is but you still got to make sure you
still got to make sure you show the love
though like i want i want people to just
work on returning that love back to
father's win and where you can uh i was
afraid of my father though really oh my
father [ __ ] shoot you [ __ ] yeah my
dad's nuts yeah my dad's not
legally like legally nuts my dad my dad
[ __ ] you up he's he's older now he on
the other side but that my dad nuts my
dad got hit in the face with an axe and
still won the fight i'll never get it
[Laughter]
yes you heard what i said
wow
in this [ __ ] right here my dad got a big
scar from here to here
uh hit in the face with an axe i never
forget he was um fighting came down he
had a bunch of towels holding his head
blood stuff coming out he
said hey get my son y'all make sure he
go back to the house yeah i'm going to
the hospital i know you look at this
[ __ ]
my kids look at me like what kind of
[ __ ]
like when he said i'm going to the
hospital i'll be back he said it like he
was going to get something to eat
i'm just casual
casual i'll be back my phone came back i
had stitches on i ain't never asked
nothing about the other guy we never but
i said if he walked out of there with
this that's a smart idea that's smart
never happened that's smart you know
that's never happened my dad was uh
he was he was heavy in that in that
world heavy in that world so you know a
lot of the a lot of the freedom that i
had growing up was because of
the work that my dad and my brother did
they did
they did different stuff they lived
different lives so my mind was uh
a little different but you once again
when you get older you respect that yeah
because you go oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] start to
make sense yeah oh that's why everybody
called me lil heart
that's a little oh that's a little rob
hart
that's a little rob hart brother right
there nah that's a little spoon
you start to realize the it's
transferred yeah so i was like the
protected dumb oblivious child oh
everybody's nice around here
they're like so nice to me
i love all these people he was [ __ ]
scared of my dad or whatever else but
they had [ __ ] to do with me but once you
get older you get smarter you see that
you see that you understand it that's
true stories right there i should i've
never even told either my brother could
probably call me what the [ __ ] is she
doing man
[Laughter]
it's like give us a restaurant
man i'm over here giving out all my
goddamn
oh my [ __ ] business
uh well mike you know i did but i did it
before i got here i would have did it
man bro [ __ ] high [ __ ] now look at me
that's probably why i'm talking like i'm
talking i'm [ __ ] up
i'm like
no mike i don't smoke i don't smoke i'm
taking a i'm taking a tyson box full of
stuff home
i can't smoke on here
[ __ ] round [ __ ] all your money yeah i
can't i can't smoke on here oh mike i'm
trying to show these people right now
how responsible i am how where
all my stupid stuff come in the dark
today's podcast is sponsored by manscape
make sure you shave your balls
i'm mike i got a big ball so it takes a
long time to get shaved around the balls
respect
the older you get the longer your balls
get
man they're hanging to the floor
[Laughter]
need something to cover it it'd be like
uh
you shave them with like a vacuum
cleaner hello kind of rainbow
because they're on the floor i didn't
get a joke he said his ball's on the
floor that's why he said vacuum you guys
come on come on guys vacuum raiser yeah
it's a great bit i got it see mike i'm
with you she sounds painful is that it
again
sounds like a nice experience but i got
the reference
so
uh you have at least two movies with uh
the rock how's that experience been with
rock yeah uh hey that's the kind of way
this [ __ ] guy presented that [ __ ] man
that's not crazy
you gotta love this
this is what's gonna make this show
great it's this right here man
he just said a simple thing so what did
you eat what the [ __ ] man
jesus christ he just pulls him out his
ass no mike it's just a
this is a general
that was just a regular question but i
appreciate you mike just said
i like i like it i like the chemistry
here man this is [ __ ] great thank you
dj is cool man you know he's uh he's a
good dude another hard worker smart
makes great movie decisions he and i we
linked at a time where it made sense for
both of us and you know i think those
were great movies for us we both still
was the movie with you and the white guy
that was in the wheelchair that was the
upside wow great movie yeah great movie
i was uh that in fatherhood oh my god
bro i'm about to say that i was about to
say that that followed what i'm talking
about
that was great
i guess i can't compliment you
in jamaica look at how the show goes
uh
those two those two are two of my
favorites um
but the one thing i like about dj is you
know outside of the
the acting world i love that his
business side is flourishing as well
like he's a he's making great business
business decisions
um and you know i think it's it's about
opening up once again those other doors
so you know the acting is just one
portion that's one check but that check
isn't gonna it's not gonna do it for you
for
life create the other one why do you
think all this [ __ ] is happening to you
what do i think um
you know you definitely gotta have a
little bit of you gotta understand that
you're blessed fortunate
and gotta attach a little luck to it too
as good as you may think you are good
yes
you gotta you you you
do not think that you are we have got it
all on them yeah don't don't don't think
that you are better than luck cause
you're not so
right plays right time definitely has a
lot to do with it but with every
opportunity um you know you got to be
prepared for it to some degree so the
luck can come with knocking it out the
park
um but sometimes right place at the
right time makes a lot of sense i say
i've been at the right place at the
right time a couple times
okay so speaking of right places right
times that's when i start yarning
somebody boarding [ __ ] shrooms
working this rooms are kicking in yeah
but y'all need to shrimp well that's why
they want to do it mike simpson you
should no listen don't [ __ ] your money
up but one day alone when you're just
chilling with your woman and stuff flick
her to it and then you're just like it's
like a yawn on him
it'll be some enlightenment out of that
yarn you know what i smell something
totally different than bad breath what
is that uh
that's a that's it's it's uh
hallucinogenic right the schumer's the
possibility yeah possible so you can get
it okay i got you
so um speaking of
did this before actually you never did
before man
i mean i no i haven't um the real
husbands of hollywood yeah tell us about
that well that was somebody you didn't
belong on that [ __ ] i'm happy dude you
know what's funny i'm i'm happy as hell
because you know that was a show that i
did in the beginning of uh
my career with bt
and you know all those guys i love man
those are some of my closest friends uh
nick cannon boris kojo dwayne martin
robin thicke jb smoove
uh nelly it was too many of you guys so
many so many and you know what man and i
know i know i'm leaving who am i leaving
now jackie long who was a part of it as
well
um
i said to wayne i said nick i said robin
i said jackie um
you know we had a lot of guests um
cynthia i want to say uh tiffany haddish
um
you know this is really good
young man right here yeah i'm just
trying to make sure that i see everybody
everybody's american
beginning
the show was crazy and it was uh it was
built off of mocking that world of
reality tv and we were one of the first
to do it and the show got a crazy
success we did five seasons yeah stop so
um i was like yo we're gonna do just
like a little encore
limited series and i think another
season it crushed and i went in i went
and basically
i went and got it because the seasons
were just sitting so i was like there's
an appetite that's when you were really
ripped you had your shirt off your [ __ ]
yeah i always had the shirt off on that
one that's when i felt like i had to
yeah had a flesh i had to just uh let
people know what was going on uh but now
we're gonna do a encore of just bringing
you back
and to so it's one of those things that
it's the most fun i have doing anything
because we could do the people yeah it's
the people you just do what we want so
many i feel like there's so many great
names in there like so i can't imagine
the stories it's just behind the scenes
[ __ ] though it's so the [ __ ] that we're
doing it's just ridiculous yeah it's
funny it's ridiculous everybody's making
fun of themselves we're all not afraid
to make fun of ourselves laugh at
ourselves uh and that's what makes so
many people it was like a basketball
team yeah it's like it's so much
i love it though and so
you actually said two movies uh
fatherhood that i thought that movie was
fire thank you man those those type of
movies five of the serious roles the one
that mike mentioned with the wheelchair
i forget the name but i saw that one
upside which was great as well when you
take take on those roles like
how do you
feel about that do you like it do you
want do you want those more serious
rules i know you have a show with wesley
snipes too like you saw a true story
yeah well people don't understand these
are all self-generated yeah you know i'm
at a point in my career in your [ __ ]
movies you lied to me that one day when
we did the commercial about the movie
[ __ ] yes what i love what i said
what do you say mike
it was me and the vanderbilt thing you
gonna put me in some movies i don't lie
can't put you in fatherhood of the
upside those aren't the two we got some
we got something coming up that i can do
you'd be getting matched you lost some
monopoly yeah these are
these are the work that we're doing now
you know we're uh
i'm able
uh hub at heartbeat so um i'm at a point
in my career where i can just
i can say what i want to do and and kind
of make it happen so you know i know i
know what i'm capable of yeah um from an
acting standpoint i know that i'm i'm a
dramatic actor as well uh i love comedy
so if and when i choose to switch it up
i will uh hit people with curveballs i
will but those action comedies or those
uh grounded versions are reality with
some comedic tone to it so
which one do you like more comedy
nothing's ever going to be ever going to
be nothing's ever going to beat
the feeling of making people laugh yeah
you know i feel like
shocking people and being serious well
you know they're the only ones that
shocked by you know that you can do it
yeah uh making people laugh is much
harder that's why comedies
come a dime a dozen and what's
considered to be good comedies versus
bad comedies it's all it's all
subjective because there's so many
different opinions of what's funny to so
many people so so now i see uh that
you're actually dipping in the crypto
world a little bit and tell me about
that crypto [ __ ] yeah what got you what
got you into that and you got a board
ape uh you know just trying to stay
current with the times all right you
don't want to be behind okay but what is
crypto
mike you'll be here all day trying to
figure out i
another
know
and the currency has potential
to possibly compete with our currency
today
uh but it's hiding currency from the
government i'm talking too much i don't
know
can cannot confirm nor deny i mean i
mean yes
company man
holy [ __ ] you know when you have we have
these different things that present
themselves um and there are ways
you know to find
financial gain
everybody's just trying to control it
they want to know where our money comes
from they want to know what's this
education come from they want to see
they want to receive for life i'm just
i'm just i'm a guided
i don't want to ever be left
behind fractured so i try to educate
myself on what i can in the now mm-hmm
and you know you gotta keep your shots
in the dark you just take some shots in
the dark so why did you choose that
board why did you choose that one um
just because
right now that's where
that's where a high volume of people
have went
uh there's been a return on it now if
this stuff turns out to be credible if
people can take nfts and uh take said
you're not in this idea
uh i could be but i haven't yet i'm i'm
i'm sorry right now i really like that
one i'm still figuring it out make sure
you yes to one person up for a long
period of time
well you do the whole thing is about
grabbing something taking that ip it's
art claiming that ip is art and then
people going and repurposes it and you
making money from it uh then there's the
world
in which people are falling in love with
which is this
world of metaverse yeah you know um
however compared to have you ever seen
ready player one
oh that's been um yeah ready player one
yeah right so ready player one if you
break it down this is a simple way to
break it down
people in this real world weren't happy
with their real lives but they got to be
a version of something else
in this
game and the person
that they became
was a highlighted individual depending
on their success in the game so some
people were the [ __ ] at the highest
level and when you met these people in
real life it wasn't about who they were
in real life it was about who they were
on the game which is crazy and that's
kind of what people are
following so the things that they're
creating and doing in this metaverse
world of fancy cars or homes or art or
etcetera
that's what you have right
it's it's it's what you it's what you
have so you know if this thing holds on
you don't even [ __ ] you know i do i i
actually i'm dipped in the crypto world
and i did and i got a couple nfts so
it's it's interesting though what scares
me the most about the metaverse though
is kind of what you said like you're
someone
you're someone in the real world but
you go on this other whole other reality
but you can do whatever you want look at
the direction everybody's going into if
that's the case you look at social media
you look at the world of uh apps and
filters yeah right everybody is now
we we're falling in love with the change
of who we are instead of staying true
yeah to the person that we are mm-hmm so
when you look at that
you're falling in love social media
people are falling in love with the idea
of avatar-ish yeah
like behavior antics yeah you know
rather than being me give me a filter
another filter ah that's what i want to
look like today it's it's a it's a weird
thing not that i'm a fan of it and it's
a good thing yeah uh i'm just
i'm just
dabbling in the space of business you
sure you don't want to try some shrooms
now no
no i don't want a shroom you're almost
done with that michael no this tastes so
smells so good man
i'm really banged out right now
i can can you imagine me over this [ __ ]
lit up and
just lit the [ __ ] up
kevin what do you think about nft that
day what the [ __ ] i think about it
i think i'm banged out
i started talking about this yeah
and if you get it out just keep shaking
whatever i say off as if i didn't say it
oh my god bye-bye career you promised me
my friend bye-bye
like uh special electrolytes and stuff
in there ph
surely
[Laughter]
well
as you can see
that is mike tyson yes
but i'm proud of my highness there you
go i'm sebastian joseph day yes and our
awesome special guest kevin hart can i
be honest yes before i go
this was dope as [ __ ]
because of the contrast
of youtube
and the comfort and conversation like
the podcast that worked
it was always good until they betrayed
me and left yeah i know he's got that
stupid thing called a crowd i'm proud to
go to
[Laughter]
the ones that work are the ones that
truly embrace like real conversation you
know it's like when they're when they're
forced they don't flow but there's a
there's a nice chemistry that you guys
have here man and i'm i'm glad i did it
hey i told you i wanted to come [ __ ]
with you regardless i really appreciate
that just because of you know the
relationship this thing here now i think
it's dope as hell and it's not gonna
change man you gotta hey rocco come over
here rocco always wanted to see but he
always acts scared when he see you
that's my guy
that's my guy how you doing champ rocco
is my guy me and rocco met uh when tyson
came to do an interview for me and i
found out that rocco was just an
all-around good kid oh yeah and he knows
good jokes rico do you have a joke for
me you gave me two fire ones last time
oh
yeah
one good joke for me before i go
what's the only good thing about
switzerland what's the only good thing
about switzerland oh this is a country
you picking on okay um hey let's see
any swedes in here i don't know rocco
let's go i know they're always here
i don't know either but the flag is a
big plus
[Laughter]
that was fun i told you to get ready
to make some good ones next time
all right last one rocco one more what
did the bear say when when he was at the
amuse amusement park what did the bears
say when he was at the amusement park
give it to me it's bearable
see what i'm saying now first of all
y'all don't you don't understand why i
love this about rocco cause i want to
know where he's getting the jokes
from your brain
you reading them you just know where
they are you just hold on to them yeah
it's the life of a great comedian i'll
see you at the top buddy yes sir okay do
me a favor give me like five more years
before you do it okay i just got a
couple more things i want to do and then
i don't mind if you push me out the way
but give me five more years can we agree
on that okay my guy my guy well they
damn it rocco is strong as hell yeah
look in their eyes
jesus christ
broke your hand he's listen he's 11
years old today left happy birthday
rocking your birthday happy birthday
happy birthday man
good for you dude i got to give him 11
years old this little kid for 11 years
11 years old
man
well there you have it that is mike
tyson i'm sebastian joseph day this is
rocco and our special guest kevin hart
check out hotboxing at hotboxing on
youtube instagram or twitter you know
the vibes we out don't forget to check
out tyson 2.0
[Music]
you